madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue sur
le plateau de la voie est libre en
direct et en Bourgogne 15 jours après
les élections départementales ce sont
les régionales qui sont au cœur de nos
préoccupations aujourd'hui et je reçois
celui qui s'est lancé le premier dès le
mois de décembre 2014 bonjour Alain
bonjour vous êtes sénateurs de
Haute-Saône et vous êtes celui que l'UMP
a désigné comme chef de fil pour ces
régionales 2015 mais à droite l'UDA elle
aussi désigné un chef de fil en
l'occurrence le député et président du
conseil départemental de la Côte-d'Or
François Sauvadet vous souhaitez donc
l'un et l'autre mener ce combat pour la
droite et pour conquérir la future
grande région Bourgogne Franche-Comté
alors on va parler de cette discorde de
la difficile union de la droite mais
aussi on va aussi parler de vous de vos
envies de vos envies pour la région et
puis de votre stratégie à la maison je
vous rappelle que vous pouvez réagir ou
poser vos questions directement à Alain
Joyandet via Twitter hashtag lvl
Bourgogne ou at F3 via notre page
Facebook ou sur notre site internet
bourgogne.france3.fr alors Alain
jouantet les Bourguignons vous
connaissent un petit peu moins que les
francs-combois si je dis que vous êtes
d'un côté un patron de presse et de
l'autre un homme politique
UMP Sarkozy de la droite forte ça vous
convient
c'est toujours un peu résumé c'est bien
normal
c'est vrai que je suis un Bourguignon au
fond vous êtes né à Dijon je suis à
Dijon je suis né dans la rue des Trois
forgerons vous savez sur la table de la
cuisine parce que ma mère a pas eu le
temps d'aller à la maternité oui je suis
né à Dijon et et ensuite comme beaucoup
j'ai bougé et j'ai fait mes études à
Dijon lycée mon Chapet un peu la faculté
ensuite j'ai créé mon entreprise en
Franche-Comté l'entreprise de presse
effectivement et puis enfin de carrière
professionnelle j'allais dire j'ai
développé cette entreprise je vais dix
dernières années sur la Bourgogne
notamment à Auxonne avec une rotative de
presse
importante une des rares rotatives
presse d'ailleurs je les fais
discrètement tout ça un magazine leader
sur son marché à Dijon et puis j'ai
également contribué à sauver le plus
ancien hebdomadaire d'informations
locales de France qui est né en 1804 et
qui se trouve à Châtillon-sur-Seine et
qui aujourd'hui marche très très bien il
a retrouvé une nouvelle jeunesse qui
veut dire d'ailleurs que la jeunesse
n'est pas une question d'âge alors il y
a quand même un mystère dans votre
carrière et notamment dans la fin de la
carrière en 2012 vous avez tout arrêté
vos mandats politiques et puis vous êtes
revenus en 2014 comme sénateur et
aujourd'hui vous vous lancez dans les
régionales pourquoi ce revirement
rejeter lui benjamin du Sénat donc en
1995 vous voyez c'est déjà et donc j'ai
quitté le Sénat pour effectivement aller
à l'Assemblée nationale à la demande de
mes amis et puis j'ai pris cette mairie
socialiste à Vesoul que j'ai géré
pendant 17 ans en 95 aussi oui en 95
aussi j'ai souhaité transmettre ces
mandats de députés de maire comme je m'y
étais engagé avant la fin du troisième
deuxième mandat et j'ai fait mon petit
break j'ai fait mon petit break je suis
retourné dans l'entreprise le temps de
la transmettre à mes enfants parce que
c'était aussi mon ma stratégie ça fait
du bien de faire quelques allers-retours
entre la politique et l'entreprise
plutôt que de faire de la politique que
de la politique pour élargir un peu son
horizon on est assez peu d'ailleurs
d'homme d'entreprises en politique quand
j'étais au gouvernement je crois j'étais
d'ailleurs autour de la table du Conseil
des ministres je crois que je devais
être à peu près le seul ou presque chef
d'entreprise et donc j'ai souhaité
évidemment revenir parce que je pense
que je peux encore apporter quelque
chose si si on m'accorde cette cette
prétention tout en étant modeste je
pense que je peux encore apporter
quelque chose à ma famille politique à
l'UMP à la Bourgogne Franche-Comté j'ai
partagé ma vie entre ces deux régions
j'ai tout de suite quand j'ai appris
cette fusion que les socialistes ont
fait d'ailleurs sans nous demander
sans nous demander notre avis au fond et
que et que j'ai et que j'ai voté les
socialistes ont souvent de bonnes idées
enfin quand il s'agit de les mettre en
œuvre je pense qu'il vaut mieux que ce
soit nous qui nous en occupions et donc
je me suis engagé dans ce combat voilà
mais par passion par enthousiasme mais
je pense qu'on aura l'occasion de
revenir sur mon projet parce que c'est
surtout mon projet que je voudrais
développer un peu aujourd'hui bien sûr
on va en parler mais qu'est-ce qui vous
motive en fait à un joyeux parce que
vous détracteurs disent oui alors là je
voyais il est passé de post en poste il
a été maire de Vesoul il a été député
conseiller départemental brièvement
conseiller régional c'est nata qu'est-ce
qui vous motivez ce que vous êtes un
insatiable ou un instable alors je crois
surtout que je suis un passionné des
affaires publiques vous savez à côté de
l'entreprise avant d'être en politique
j'étais déjà président de mon club de
football pendant 10 ans que j'ai monté
en National on a fait des belles euh
des belles prestations en Coupe de
France de Paris Saint-Germain Monaco la
petite ville de Vesoul vous voyez donc
j'ai la passion de ces de cet engagement
public au service des autres franchement
je le fais pas pour des questions
personnelles j'ai montré si vous voulez
mon désintéressement vous savez quand on
quitte le Sénat en 2002 pour aller
l'Assemblée nationale mes copains au
Sénat ils m'ont dit mais attends mais tu
es fou tu quittes pas le Sénat pour
l'Assemblée nationale je l'ai fait parce
que j'aime entreprendre j'aime la vie
j'aime faire des choses régulièrement
j'aime bien aussi m'attaquer à d'autres
objectifs et donc c'est ça mon état
d'esprit je sais moi je suis un
entrepreneur je suis positif j'aime la
j'aime la vie en communauté faire des
choses ensemble c'est ça qui me
passionne et donc au fond avant de
m'engager j'ai regardé autour de moi
dans ma famille politique est-ce que
quelqu'un veut y aller est-ce que
quelqu'un veut s'y coller à cette à
cette nouvelle région Bourgogne
Franche-Comté j'ai fait le tour de tous
les parlementaires de de Franche-Comté
et de Bourgogne et tout le monde a
encouragé et donc du coup je me suis
engagé avec détermination et je dois
dire une certaine passion on va une
dernière question avant de venir
vraiment au régional sur les réseaux
sociaux depuis que vous vous êtes
déclaré notamment vos adversaires ne se
prive pas de rappeler le plus souvent
impossible votre démission du
gouvernement avec du jet privé et puis
du permis de construire contester que
vous auquel vous avez d'ailleurs renoncé
c'est l'histoire ancienne vous allez
regretté ces épisodes ça vous a fait
changer
bien sûr mais je n'ai jamais regretté je
me suis d'ailleurs jamais excusé vous
savez j'ai fait mon travail de ministre
on m'a envoyé faire ce travail je l'ai
fait je ne regrette pas j'ai eu une
carrière ministérielle très dense
pendant trois ans j'ai fait 60 plus de
70 déplacements dans le monde entier
donc presque 40 secrétaire d'État
à la coopération et la francophonie j'ai
donc dû utiliser au total je crois 70
fois les avions j'ai en gros fait un
tiers dans les avions de ligne un tiers
dans les avions du gouvernement un tiers
dans les avions privés j'ai fait mon
travail mon cabinet a fait les choses
comme il comme il fallait les choses
étaient bien négociées évidemment je
sais bien si vous voulez que que les
chiffres qui sont annoncés peuvent
choquer nos concitoyens mais enfin après
moi il y en a un autre sont les
socialistes qui sont gouvernement je
peux pas traverser l'Atlantique à la
rame c'est pas possible et on peut
toujours essayer ça marche pas donc
aujourd'hui les avions continuent de de
voler dans le ciel pour le rayonnement
de la France je crois avoir contribué au
rayonnement de mon pays j'ai organisé
notamment la grande conférence entre les
États africains et la France la demande
du président Sarkozy j'ai fait mon
boulot voilà et donc ça fait ça fait
partie de la vie politique il peut y
avoir des polémiques j'ai jugé à un
moment donné que dans cette polémique il
n'était pas possible de continuer à
travailler sereinement j'ai préféré
prendre du recul c'était ma
responsabilité je précise d'ailleurs une
chose c'est qu'on va pas demander de
quitter le gouvernement c'est moi qui
l'ai fait c'est un peu l'avantage aussi
de des gens de l'entreprise si je ne
dépends pas de la politique moi je suis
indépendant de la politique je fais ça
par passion je fais pas pour des
questions matérielles et donc j'ai
quitté le gouvernement mais j'ai
retrouvé j'ai retrouvé l'entreprise
familiale que j'ai créée quand j'avais
24 ans qui maintenant est géré par mes
enfants très jeunes aussi et donc je
suis totalement disponible pour pour cet
échéance et je le dis d'ailleurs à vos
téléspectateurs j'ai fait le choix de la
région je ne fais que ce choix là et j'y
suis depuis quatre mois et donc je vais
continuer exclusivement donc vous
partirez du Sénat au cas où vous
réussissiez si j'étais président
de la Région Bourgogne Franche-Comté et
que à un moment donné je sois en
situation de cumul des mandats il est
clair que je resterai bien évidemment
président de la région alors justement
c'est cette régionale alors vous avez
dit votre motivation c'est aussi le fait
que soit une grande région qui qui fait
que donc il y aura très peu de
présidents finalement c'est aussi une
motivation ça ma vraie motivation c'est
que la région c'est le pouvoir
économique c'est le développement
économique sont les entreprises c'est
l'emploi et c'est la relation entre la
collectivité les collectivités
territoriales et le monde de l'économie
c'est ce que j'ai fait toute ma vie
voilà pendant 30 ans j'ai été chef
d'entreprise et en même temps élu comme
vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure à
différents postes qui me permettent
aujourd'hui d'avoir cette cette double
cette double expérience assez peu de
gens ont finalement du monde privé du
monde politique de l'entreprise de
l'intérêt général en même temps et je
pense que je peux être utile à ce poste
pour cette région Bourgogne
Franche-Comté alors je vais vous poser
une question de Christian qui nous a
laissé ça sur notre site internet je
veux tuer MP mais je ne comprends pas
pourquoi l'UMP ne présente pas un
Bourguignon pour la prochaine élection
régionale ça risque de vous revenir
Christian vous êtes un peu bourguignon
contact avec moi et on ira faire un tour
rue des Trois forgerons je lui ai fait
visiter aussi le lycée Montchapet à
Dijon donc voilà vous savez aujourd'hui
tout ça
sa change je veux dire il y a des Francs
courtois en Bourgogne je rencontre
beaucoup et il y a aussi des
Bourguignons en Franche-Comté
vous savez
ça joue pas beaucoup je vais dire que
mais j'ai cette chance c'est d'avoir
cette je vais pas parler de nationalité
je sais pas comment il faut dire la
régionalité j'essaie de double
régionalité entre la Bourgogne et la
Franche-Comté depuis la vallée de la
Saône vous savez il y a aussi la vallée
de la vin Jeanne où toute ma famille ses
graines en Côte-d'Or Fontaine-Française
Mirebeau
arceau etc dans tout Dijon bien
évidemment donc la TI voyez tout ça tout
ça c'est la c'est un mélange de
Bourgogne et de Franche-Comté et ça me
va très bien alors on l'a dit le
président
udi du conseil départemental de la
Côte-d'Or en temps lui aussi mener la
liste de droite et du sang que vous avez
tous les deux fait une sorte d'appel à
l'Union tous les deux assez clairement
mais en gros c'est un peu l'Union dans
la des unions c'est chacun de son côté
c'est ça non parce que je voudrais je
voudrais vous dire quand même sur ce sur
ce sujet là moi depuis quatre mois je
suis en campagne je n'ai pas
critiqué non pas les adversaires mais
les collègues de la grande famille de la
droite et du centre l'UDI
l'UMP on n'est pas frère jumeau
madame Jouanno dit d'ailleurs que l'UDI
n'a pas les mêmes valeurs que l'UMP
madame Jounot c'est la personne qui va
qui était d'ailleurs une collègue au
gouvernement qui va qui va mener la
liste udi en Île de France et le dit
l'UMP et l'UDI n'ont pas les mêmes
valeurs c'est elle qui le dit c'est pas
moi donc je dis simplement que dans cet
appel à l'union
ce que je regrette c'est que ça ça
voudrait dire qu'il que certains sont
favorables pour cette union et d'autres
seraient des diviseurs et on voudrait me
faire passer pour un diviseur alors vous
savez
la politique est là c'est c'est travers
comme ça c'est ces montages ces écrans
de fumée on a bien on est bien dans on
est bien là-dedans c'est tous c'est tout
ce dont les Français ne veulent plus ils
veulent qu'on s'occupe d'eux et j'espère
qu'on va avoir le temps de parler de ce
projet mais quand même je voudrais vous
dire quelque chose quand j'ai dans mon
équipe à mes côtés à la houppère
sénateur de la Côte d'Or
UMP mais qui a quand même avec un
Catherine loisir récupérer deux juste
des sénateurs en Côte-d'Or plus de 900 m
en Côte-d'Or Jacques Barthélémy ancien
préfet de région qui est à mes côtés
aussi adjoint au maire de Chamboeuf dans
la dans la Côte d'Or dans la sonnet
Loire jean-Patrick Courtois
Jean-Paul aymorin sénateur également de
ce de ce département Gilles plâtré le
nouveau maire de Chalon que j'ai
d'ailleurs soutenu dans la décision
qu'il a prise de supprimer les menus de
substitution dans ces quand il m'en aura
peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir
monsieur Duplessis qui est président
d'une belle interco également dans la
dans la Saône-et-Loire quand dans
l'Yonne Henri drincourt notamment
Jean-Baptiste Lemoine et sénateurs
Jean-Baptiste Lemoine élu au premier
tour de cette élection départementale
dans son dans son département quand je
vois que
des gens comme Eric gentil Aurélie
berger tous ces noms vont dire quelque
chose au bourguignon
je suis allé soutenir aussi une jeune
candidate Valérie leger qui vient de
gagner les élections départementales
contre l'adjoint au maire de la ville de
d'Auxerre
j'ai dans tous les départements de cette
nouvelle région Bourgogne Franche-Comté
des relais qui parlent quand même dans
même dans la Nièvre dans la Nièvre où je
suis allé soutenir monsieur rostin qui
vient d'être élu et puis je pourrais
continuer la liste comme ça sur la santé
quand on dit Damien meslo député-mère de
Belfort et ni jeune Var député maire de
Morteau qui représente la partie
montagne que la Franche-Comté va
apporter à la Bourgogne j'espère qu'on
aura le temps d'en parler aussi Jacques
gros Perrin qui est qui est le comment
dire l'urbain de de ce groupe à Besançon
etc etc mon ami Michel Raison qui va
pouvoir m'aider sur les questions
d'agriculture sénateurs de la de la
Haute-Saône Marie-Christine DALO ce qui
est député de vous voyez que vous avez
beaucoup de jeunes filles pas seul mais
je voudrais insister là-dessus parce que
franchement vouloir me faire passer pour
un diviseur quelque part je pense qu'à
un moment donné je crois que ça s'arrête
parce que si
Françoise veut qu'à un moment donné on
se on se retrouve je pense qu'il faut
vraiment que c'est ces caricatures c'est
et puis que c'est ces aficionados ou
c'est twittos comment on dit hein ce
calme un petit peu chercher depuis
quatre mois où j'ai pu moins dire un mot
négatif sur le dei ou sur mes
partenaires de la majorité je me trompe
pas d'adversaires mes adversaires ce
sont les socialistes mon projet il est
fait pour mettre fin à 10 ans de gestion
socialiste dans les régions Bourgogne
Franche-Comté pour que les noter les
spectateurs comprennent je vous propose
d'écouter justement François sauvadélu
quelle est sa position et puis on va y
revenir juste après c'était le jour de
sa réélection à la tête du conseil
départemental de la Côte-d'Or écouter le
il y a un seul message que je souhaite
faire passer aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a
pas de place pour les divisions il y a
pas de place pour les aventures
individuelles quel que soit les
élections à venir c'est bien pour les
élections régionales que pour les
élections lég
islatives ou les élections
présidentielles l'Union ce sera une
obligation à l'âge ayantais n'est pas
dans ces stratégie il souhaite de liste
de bonnes stratégie que je pense bonne
pour l'avenir de la Bourgogne
Franche-Comté et ben voilà je vais
travailler à l'Union
et puis le choix des hommes interviendra
ensuite mais d'abord l'Union
alors en gros il dit que votre stratégie
c'est deux listes pour le premier tour
alors est-ce que c'est vraiment ça ça
rejoint d'ailleurs une question de d'un
téléspectateur sur Twitter joyeux
n'a-t-il pas changé d'avis sur une liste
unique n'a-t-il pas dit en mars qu'il
voulait deux listes à droite au premier
tour d'abord je voudrais répondre à
François souvannet que j'ai été investi
à l'unanimité des 50 membres de la
commission nationale d'investiture de
l'UMP et ratifier par le Conseil
national de de l'UMP nous ne sommes que
7 en France à avoir eu cette légitimité
de notre mouvement au niveau national il
y aurait donc il y a donc pas un
candidat légitime et un candidat qu'il
n'est pas on voit pas tellement sur
quels critères je suis même tenté de
dire que on pourrait presque dire pas
parce que c'est moi mais que j'ai un
petit peu plus de légitimité du fait que
le poids de l'UMP est beaucoup plus
important que le poids de l'UDI alors
le poids électoral bien évidemment nous
ne sommes pas dans une région centriste
nous sommes dans une région UMP et les
choses sont très
par le Conseil national donc c'est
quelque chose qui est derrière nous il
faut se retrouver avec lui il faut se
retrouver avec l'UDI mais je voudrais le
dire et j'insiste là-dessus dans les
conditions qui soient des conditions sur
le plan humain en termes d'ambiance et
moi j'aime pas les conflits j'aime être
positif j'ai entreprendre j'ai un projet
je voudrais qu'on en parle je voudrais
qu'on parle du projet j'ai d'ailleurs vu
que monsieur sigenot le Président de
l'UMP dans le dans le en Côte-d'Or
n'avait pas signé ce fameux appel à une
nuit pose des bonnes questions il dit
c'est quoi c'est quoi cette affaire
c'est pour faire quoi où il est le
projet voilà moi j'ai un projet
j'aimerais qu'on en parle et j'ajoute
que d'ailleurs je suis le seul
décider décidément dans beaucoup de dans
beaucoup de circonstances à faire les
choses à peu près correctement en tout
cas j'essaye moi j'ai déclaré ma
candidature
j'ai ouvert mon compte de campagne pour
l'instant je ne vois pas d'autres
candidatures officielles et les gens qui
parlent ici ou là qu'il risque d'être
candidat ou pas sont tous à la tête d'un
exécutif déjà moi je n'ai pas d'exécutif
je me consacre à la région
on sait bien quand même pour terminer
avec ça on sait bien qu'il y a aussi
derrière l'enjeu des primaires à la pour
la présidentielle on voit qu'il y a des
tractations entre l'umpud entre Nicolas
Sarkozy et Jean-Christophe Lagarde
est-ce que vous êtes sûr d'avoir le
soutien de Nicolas Sarkozy écoutez je
n'ai eu que des encouragements de
semaine en semaine mais je connais la
vie publique je connais la vie politique
voilà les tractations et les existent
elles ont existé continueront d'exister
hélas parce que je préfère de loin que
les choses s'organisent sur le terrain
je préfère de loin que l'on parle avec
les parties de la droite
républicaine et plutôt que d'attendre je
ne sais quel bénédiction en tout cas moi
je ne m'occupe pas de ça je trace ma
route j'ai un projet j'ai une équipe
j'ai une stratégie j'ai ouvert mes deux
premiers QG de campagne à Dijon et à
Besançon je vais continuer pour les 8
départements et je pense que c'est ça
que nos concitoyens attendent mais c'est
Nicolas Sarkozy qui doit trancher
écoutez on verra ce qui va se passer
dans les jours qui viennent dans les
semaines qui viennent moi je pense qu'il
faut laisser un peu de temps au temps
travaillons que chacun apporte sa
contribution que le débat public soit
nourri pour l'instant j'ai le sentiment
que je suis un peu seul à faire ce
travail de fond je voudrais vraiment
qu'on en parle on va y arriver une
dernière question parce que ça il y a
des questions aussi là-dessus est-ce que
si jamais fait de la politique fiction
mais c'est un peu aussi notre rôle si
jamais François Sauvadet avait
l'investiture umpudie vous seriez prêt
aller derrière lui ou non vous
montreriez votre propre liste écoutez
aujourd'hui nous en sommes à la
situation que vous avez décrite n'est-ce
pas et bien laissons les jours venir ou
les semaines venir
le moment le moment viendra et là je
suis d'accord avec ce qui a été dit tout
à l'heure par François souvendé Sauvadet
le choix des hommes interviendra plus
tard et vous savez je vais faire une
petite précision quand même
parce qu'on a beaucoup d'îles et par des
départementales on les éloigner grâce à
l'Union je ne suis pas arc-bouté pour
qu'il y ait deux listes s'il n'y a
qu'une liste une umpud je suis prêt à la
conduire comme je l'ai fait en 2010
toute ma vie politique toute ma vie
politique pour être efficace j'ai tenté
et réussi à chaque fois le rassemblement
le plus large possible c'est ce que j'ai
fait dans la ville de Vesoul que j'ai
géré pendant 17 ans que j'ai pris au
socialiste et que j'ai transmis à un
jeune pour me succéder et donc il n'y a
pas de problème pour ceux qui je suis à
fond mais je veux quand même dire que
pour les élections régionales parce que
nous concitoyens ne savent pas pour se
maintenir au deuxième tour il faut faire
10% des suffrages exprimés au premier
tour des suffrages exprimés au
départemental c'est 12 et demi pour cent
des inscrits ça n'a rien à voir ça n'a
rien à voir donc ce sont deux élections
différentes il y a la proportionnelle
d'un côté une élection il nominale de
l'autre ça n'a rien à voir l'important
c'est de se retrouver au moins au
deuxième tour si possible au premier
tour en gros je l'ai entre les lignes ça
veut dire que il n'y a pas de
c'est ça que vous voulez dire il y a pas
de risque que vous soyez éliminé
éventuellement par le Front national en
tout cas l'UMP n'a aucun risque qu'une
liste UMP n'a aucun risque d'être
éliminé
au dès le premier tour pour ne pas
accéder au deuxième tour et cette région
Bourgogne Franche-Comté ne fait pas
partie des régions qui peuvent être
prises par le Front national d'accord et
le Front national mais risque d'être
devant quand même c'est pas grave
puisque vous me parlez du Front national
peut-être pouvons-nous en dire un mot
sur la hauteur de cette de cette
formation de cette formation aujourd'hui
qui évidemment inquiète beaucoup
les Françaises et les Français en tout
cas un certain nombre
il faut il faut je pense avoir aussi une
autre façon d'aborder ce sujet là je
pense qu'on peut pas continuer à montrer
du doigt ce qui vote pour le Front
national je pense qu'il faut qu'on se
pose des questions
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait depuis 10 ans 20
ans 30 ans qui fait que la France petit
à petit se déclasse qui fait que les
familles sont inquiète qui fait qu'il y
a deux 200 6000 chômeurs en Bourgogne
Franche-Comté 206000 chômeurs en
Bourgogne Franche-Comté qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pour répondre à cette situation
comment notre société évolue quelle est
la vraie inquiétude sociétale des
Françaises et des Français moi je
souhaite qu'on se remette en cause et
quand j'entends les consignes de vote
parce qu'on perd une élection et qu'on
n'est pas là au deuxième tour et qu'on
dit à nos supporters à nous à nos
militants à nous on n'a pas pu être
présent au deuxième tour et en plus on
va vous expliquer pour qui il faut voter
les Françaises et les Français ils sont
très grands ils sont faut pas les il
faut pas les infantiliser ils ont tous
les éléments en main ils votent pour qui
ils veulent ils sont suffisamment
adultes pour le faire c'est cette
nouvelle façon aussi d'aborder la
politique que je voudrais incarner et à
nous d'avoir de véritables projets pour
s'attaquer au vrai sujet la sécurité les
régions ont la charge des vous savez la
violence existe la violence existe il
faut faire quelque chose et on peut être
qu'on y reviendra tout à l'heure et je
pense à ce nouveau modèle de société que
nous devons regarder étudier je pense
qu'avec Nicolas Sarkozy on est en train
de faire ce travail de fond et j'espère
que très vite on pourra proposer une
vraie alternative aux Français leur
retourne vite on va passer un peu à vos
priorités avec une question de Ben aussi
d'un internaute Paul vous êtes parti en
campagne donc depuis plusieurs mois et
cela selon vous dire pour pouvoir
travailler à un projet alors quel état
des lieux vous avez dressé en gros
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner
quelques unes de vos priorités alors on
va fusionner deux régions Bourgogne et
Franche-Comté c'est un peu comme quand
on fusionne deux entreprises je je
mélange pas les gens je sais bien que
c'est pas la même chose mais quand même
moi j'ai abordé la gestion de la vie
dont j'ai été le maire pendant 17 ans
avec mes mes grands mes grands principes
de la gestion et du et du développement
je pense que c'est la même chose pour la
Bourgogne Franche-Comté il faut
d'ailleurs faire déjà état des lieux
l’état des lieux n'est pas très brillant
la fusion de nos deux régions fera en
sorte que nous serons jamais que la
onzième région sur 13 nous avons une
natalité
en Bourgogne et en Franche-Comté qui est
nettement inférieur à celle de la France
de la moyenne française donc je pense
que nos deux régions sont en train de
s'endormir un peu il y a lieu de les
réveiller ça c'est le constat on a par
ailleurs un système industriel dans ces
régions nos organisations industrielle
dans ces régions qui n'est pas assez
soutenue par la collectivité
territoriale or je pense que ce c'est la
région qui doit faire ce travail alors
face à ce constat d'une future grande
région très belle une des plus belles
régions de France elle est presque dire
une des plus belles régions d'Europe qui
va rassembler
ce que connaît la Bourgogne je vais pas
l'expliquer évidemment au bourguignon
ici mais moi je voudrais contribuer à
faire en sorte que les Bourguignons les
franc-comtoises connaissent mieux je le
dis qui nous écoutent là Franche-Comté
va apporter la montagne la Franche-Comté
va apporter son industrie la
Franche-Comté la première région
industrielle de France la Bourgogne est
une des régions les plus connues au
monde grâce aux vins si on met tout ça
ensemble on doit faire vraiment quelque
chose de formidable c'est ça ma passion
c'est ça que j'ai envie de faire mais
justement c'est quoi pour vous cette
fusion finalement est-ce que c'est
essayer de créer une identité Bourgogne
Franche-Comté ou c'est plus un outil
administratif pour développer un
territoire tout part de la
simplification de l'organisation
territoriale bon les socialistes ont
pris la décision j'y reviens pas c'est
la loi de la République moi je l'ai voté
est-ce que c'est un enjeu pour que vous
pensez que la région sera plus forte
comme ça vous savez on dit toujours
qu'il faut réformer et à chaque fois
qu'on nous propose une réforme on dit
non je pense qu'à un moment donné il
faut quand même il faut quand même
avancer donc c'est pas forcément ce que
ce qui était l'idéal c'est une réforme
qui est très complexe c'est la loi donc
du 16 janvier 2015
qui est très très compliqué je vais pas
entrer là-dedans mais donc on a on
devant nous cet objectif alors est-ce
qu'on s'y colle ou est-ce qu'on s'y
colle pas moi j'ai envie de m'y coller
et je j'ai un projet évidemment
aujourd'hui sur lequel on travaille
depuis fort longtemps sur toute la
partie institutionnelle d'ailleurs j'ai
des idées peut-être qu'on y avait un
tout à l'heure je sais pas à quel moment
vous voulez qu'on aborde c'est-à-dire
des idées parce qu'on peut pas changer
les institutions comme ça si je parle de
la fusion institutionnelle moi mon
projet s'articule autour de trois
piliers il y a d'abord
un peu autour des r de la lettre R vous
voyez il faut réussir il faut réussir la
fusion il faut relancer l'économie et il
faut rayonner grâce à l'excellence voilà
en clair ce projet que nous sommes en
train d'incuber avec bfc8 BFC 8 qui est
un incubateur d'idées d'ailleurs on peut
aller voir j'encourage
sur le site pour apporter leur
contribution parce que sur la méthode je
voudrais que vraiment que on rentre dans
la nouvelle politique je voudrais pas
que ce soit quelque chose qui se fait
par quelques-uns mais que beaucoup de
gens participent
ça veut dire ce ne sera plus une fusion
association mais ça ressemble à une
fusion absorption et bien on en reparle
dans un instant mais là il va être midi
je vous propose de jeter un coup d'oeil
sur l'actualité en Bourgogne le flash
est présenté ce midi par les ériger à
tout de suite